Speaker 1: . As if things weren't a tinderbox
already, Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
is now suggesting a real insurrection on his
program.
Now, the term real insurrection is, of course,
Tucker playing coy with the January 6th Trump
riots.
Tucker and others claim that January 6th was
not really an insurrection.
And when they say that, it's never totally
clear if they mean it's not really an insurrection
because it failed
Speaker 5: or
Speaker 1: it's not an insurrection because
it wasn't really meant to be an insurrection.
In any case, we've talked before about stochastic
terrorism and this idea that with a large
enough audience, even subtly, if you put an
idea into people's minds, someone becomes
likely to go and actually do the thing.
If you suddenly put the idea in an audience
of one hundred people to go and kill someone,
it's not super likely that someone's really
going to do it.
But if your audience is a thousand or ten
thousand or a million or ten million, once
it gets to be a large audience, that subtle
idea becomes more and more likely to actually
influence someone in the crowd to do it.
Go and do the thing you're subtly suggesting
they do in this clip.
Tucker's not even floating the idea subtly.
He's just saying, why don't we have a real
insurrection and why does he want one?
Well, because of misstatements that his guest,
the mayor of Uvalda, Texas, Don McGlaughlin,
tells about immigration.
These are lies about immigration.
And it makes Tucker say, what about a real
insurrection over this?
Take a look that the people
Speaker 6: coming north from Latin America,
Central America, a lot of cases are aware
that there's a new administration in the United
States and the policies are different.
Speaker 5: Oh, most definitely.
They're telegraphing it down to what do you
when you see t shirts with people say by the
let me in by the let me.
And they're all over.
I mean, you know, it's telegraphed back down
to one of them comes over and they'll tell
you soon as I get over and get to call them
back home when I'm selling to and more to
come that I got the end.
Come on.
We're sending a message at home.
The borders open.
Come on in.
Do what you want.
I mean, what why aren't we enforcing the laws
that are on the book?
They're already on the book that says you
can't cross the border illegally or whatever,
but we're going to reward you with putting
you in a nice hotel or or give you a fourteen
hundred dollar Visa card debit card that you
can use while you're here in the States you
get established or whatever.
And how many times they replenish.
Speaker 1: You mean give a
Speaker 5: 14 hour Visa debit card?
I haven't been able to confirm this yet, but
I have told that they're giving you these
immigrant families.
They're in these hotels.
They're giving them a fourteen dollar I mean,
a 14 hour Visa card.
Speaker 1: They think, why don't we have a
real insurrection at some point?
Like why why
Speaker 5: would we put up with this?
Well, in my opinion, you're closer than you've
ever been in our country of getting to that.
I think we're closer.
I feel closer to that.
I mean,
Speaker 1: this is absolutely it's beyond
insulting.
It's it's oppressing the population.
So there's a lot there.
Now, before we get into the really crazy part
from Tucker, Don McGlaughlin there, the mayor
of Uvalde, Texas, said illegal aliens are
getting fourteen hundred bucks.
This is related to the stimulus package that
the number fourteen hundred is not a coincidence.
Fourteen hundred was what was in the Biden
stimulus package.
The claim they make is undocumented immigrants
are getting fourteen hundred dollar stimulus
checks.
It's not true.
If an immigrant is here illegally, they won't
have a Social Security number, which you need
to have in order to get a stimulus check.
Biden's covid-19 relief package excludes most
immigrants who are not in the United States
legally from getting stimulus checks.
The relief packages during the Trump era did
the same thing.
It's the same.
There's no difference.
Only non-citizens who are here authorized
to work who can get a Social Security number
can get the stimulus.
However, according to some in the Associated
Press, some people who entered the US on valid
temporary working visas, which makes them
eligible for a social if they overstayed,
they might accidentally get the fourteen hundred
dollars.
This is a tiny number of people and it's a
distraction.
And the idea that just any old and undocumented
immigrant is getting fourteen hundred dollars
is completely wrong.
It's been widely debunked.
But let's get to the really wacky part.
This real insurrection that Tucker Carlson
wants.
This is very dangerous.
Now, I am very close to a free speech absolutist.
And what I mean by that is I believe any speech
that is not actually illegal is legal and
thus should be allowed, period.
Is that legal?
That's a call for violence.
It's a real call for violence.
It's a clear call for violence.
It's not subtle.
It's not using coded language, this type of
thing.
Is the actually illiberal, anti-democratic,
authoritarian threat that we've been talking
about, what immigrants get fourteen hundred,
I don't even know if that's true, but what
about a real insurrection?
Yes, let's do it.
Why not?
Right.
And then you go back to those claims made
in court by some of the Trump writers from
January six.
Fox News made me do it, your honor.
Sir, my client was suffering from Fox itis
and Fox mania and Fox dimentia.
It's not really their fault.
And as outrageous as we've been saying it
is for the party of personal responsibility
to say that thing I did, it was Trump and
Fox's fault.
Well, no, you deserve to be held accountable.
But then when Tucker says, how about a real
insurrection, you genuinely are starting to
muddy it up and make it even more complex
to apportion blame and responsibility.
Now, one last thing.
If such an insurrection happened, thanks to
Tucker Carlson, Tucker Carlson is not going
to be on the front lines leading it.
You understand that, right?
Tucker will be at his country club or at his
vacation home.
Tucker is like Trump in that they both value
their viewers and supporters, respectively,
as far as they are useful to them.
But these people, the people that voted for
Trump, donated to Trump, rioted for Trump
on January 6th.
The people that watch Tucker and would be
likely to do what he says when he says, what
about a real insurrection?
These are the people that Tucker, like Trump,
spent their lives trying to stay away from
and be isolated from.
They don't care about those people beyond
their immediate utility, either for ratings
or buying Tucker's book, has Tucker written
a book?
I don't know, or voting for Trump or donating
to Trump or whatever the case may be.
And in that way, Tucker and Trump are actually
very similar.
They're disgusted by their followers.
They have disdain for their followers, but
they understand that these are the people
that ultimately are responsible for writing
the checks that keep them in power or whatever.
The case may be disgusting stuff and almost
as disgusting as this.
Next thing, we're going to look at